foreign
hey guys we have something really
important to announce before we even get
into the show and that is the live show
that we're going to be doing the
lifeline live show and it is on October
19th 6 p.m Pacific and why is it October
19th it's my birthday it's his birthday
show uh we previously we previously
announced that we were going to do a
live show on moment but we realized
we're going to do it our way that's not
happening but this is October 19th watch
lifeline.com that's the website the live
show is us taking live callers the show
will be will be available to watch after
it's over so there is that but join us
live buy a ticket join the Discord we're
doing calls uh all through the Discord
so that's how you do that and uh it's
gonna be awesome I mean we wanted to do
this for a while now because a lot of
times we have more questions for you
with the videos that come in but we can
ask you we want to get into it yeah
because the videos are just the videos
but this is a live call so this is gonna
be great interactive back and forth
can't wait to interact with you guys uh
all the links are available on the
website watch lifeline.com so don't be
all like where do I get it tickets are
on sale now 15 and guess what the price
is going up closer to the event so get
it now dude get involved call us talk to
us and uh we'll chill October 19th my
birthday I'm so young
Lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or licensed professional
[Music]
hello hello hello hello hello
[Music]
recording all around Gordon all around
that's a dildo
um recording all around
with my dildo already crash
I did it though sorry oh no well I said
the dildo thing first yeah but you set
me up and I knocked it on down knocked
it on down you know it's like the Home
Run Derby you saw
so Russian is Like Home Run Derby what's
up with the orange shirt I like it
what's up with it is it new world it's
old but it's old but it's new to me
uh pretty good in Montreal
oh really yeah that's a very French
thing to buy actually yeah uh this
amazing story I wish I remember the name
of vintage though but they had a bunch
of older Wrangler shirts and I love the
Wrangler is that a Wrangler shirt this
is a Wrangler shirt oh cool I got a red
Wrangler shirt I got a blue Wrangler
shirt I got a a purple Wrangler shirt
and I got a magenta Wrangler the worst
story I've ever heard in my life
the way you told it to a children's
[ __ ] YouTube show a children's book
um I'm gonna take my pure Spectrum
gummies right here oh yeah
uh yeah my son just fell in the
background
so I'm gonna take a pure Spectrum gummy
and you can go to show notes down there
if you're a um if you're a uh a guy who
enjoys CBD
all business and if it helps just all
Biz today just go down I talked about
your shirt just go down to the show
notes and you can click on it and then
type in
um lifeline and get the 10 off look at
the ten percent off no but your tone was
really well I don't know see what's up
dude well uh you know what about you
know what's up I had my first full day
of advice sessions yesterday
yeah and I was cooking with gas it was
just boom boom boom boom one after
another I was in the zone I was [ __ ] I
was [ __ ] kid I was [ __ ] killing it
dude and everybody was cool some serious
stuff some less serious stuff but you
know what I love everybody who did it
well come to me with some seriously
secret stuff close to their heart you
know what I mean that they don't tell
anybody else matalia.com get your
appointment do it up do you like do you
love everyone
so far I don't know I mean in general no
no you're not one of those guys I'm one
of those people that hates everybody
until I meet them and then I'm like oh I
like that person interesting but that's
like kind of just true in general like
you get two sides of people on two into
like an award and they hate each other
but then they meet face to face and then
they like actually we're actually people
right yeah exactly yeah that's you yeah
whenever you're like somewhere yeah I'm
like oh wow this guy's actually a person
a guy who's like in front of me in line
who I'm like [ __ ] I'm like looking at
the back of his ears and I'm like I hate
his [ __ ] ears oh something like that
yeah and then like I meet the guys I
don't even think about his ears my uh
I've had things where I don't like
somebody and then for and I know them
and then I don't like them and we don't
talk for years and then we have a
conversation and I'm like oh yeah
they're just a person yeah and that's
that's but why do you not like them in
the first place
or something yeah you got beef I have
had beef and now I have a beef a busy
bone you know do you oh yeah yeah
he clapped he clapped at me and I would
say clap back but I did not clap at him
at first we I actually was a witness
yeah you were a witness of this to this
he came to The Comedy Store yeah I mean
I fully remember it because he was so
wacky yeah I use the word wacky because
it was just a wacky thing that he did it
was wacky and he and he came up and he
was just I brought him to my
[ __ ] Interruption and he kept
saying over and over again and over and
over it was crazy he was interrupting
himself to say pardon the [ __ ]
he was and at least 15 times I know it
was so crazy and I know he's busy bone
but in that situation he was Crazy Bone
and it was so much and then he clapped
at me on his why did he what happened he
was like back up like what did I talk
about this on my podcast I break down
the whole thing on congratulations
subscribe by the way to Super cult
Studios yeah yeah
um we really appreciate it and hit that
Bell notification and all that [ __ ] you
know talking so fast on cooking um
and so and so he yeah he came up and
interrupted at the comedy store and then
I I talked about that on my podcast a
long time ago by the way this also that
was yes it was a decade ago it might not
you might not even have had your podcast
yet in fact you probably didn't
yeah I mean it was so long I don't know
but and then so he he did that thing
that I talked about on my podcast and
then the I mean this was a while ago
right bro
and then he just recently
I don't know if it's a podcast or what
but he's been like streaming on YouTube
or he's just like and he and he was like
so I'm gonna talk to you about Chris the
[ __ ] yeah I'm not gonna say his name
and um and he talked [ __ ] about me and
he was like why not you at my show I'm
in the zone I can't be giving you and
I'm like this is not even the [ __ ]
story I told also it wasn't his show it
was your show that's what I'm saying you
know why he came up in the first place
no he came up see Faison yeah yeah
because he was a fan of Faison he's a
fan you were talking to Faison I know
it's like a phase on love yeah he comes
up and the reason he's saying pardon the
[ __ ] in the rush is because he
interrupted you in Faison yes I know
that yeah I mean I didn't know if you
knew that no I knew that okay but I
don't know why he didn't why he thought
that I was at his show after hearing my
story that legitimately says everything
that happened oh cause he's crazy bomb
he's busy being crazy busy being Crazy
Bone yeah I mean that was I didn't even
understand one of you sent me the link
yeah and I was like what
did something else happen no but yeah
because it was so obviously but I don't
I don't even want to clap back and I'm
not clapping back I'm just like dude you
just have it wrong and it's fine and I
know that he's like he's gonna clap back
again dude and I'm not even clapping
he's clapping I'm not even clapping he's
tremendously wrong whatever that's not
even close to right it wasn't it wasn't
his show now I know I hope his streams
go well I walked up off the street he
had a Walkman a CD player walking on in
the 2000s for that you're right I do
remember that this was not 1989. wow
because he was getting he was lifting
the Bone Thugs dude maybe yeah but I
whatever was he had a portable CD player
and headphones like it was 1993 and he
kept saying part of the [ __ ]
Interruption right I know
so you guys know what happened and we
could probably get phase on left to back
it up he doesn't remember he was high as
[ __ ] no doubt but also yeah but whatever
it was only memorable to me because I
was like oh my God I [ __ ] love him I
know me too dude yeah
for sure and I'm gonna miss everybody
yeah yeah so anyway dude that's the
whole beef thing you can subscribe to
the [ __ ] you get more stories about Busy
Bone and also plenty more but subscribe
to Super cult Studios and um and that's
it and and that that you know I don't
know but it's been so [ __ ] hot in L.A
and I'm happy that today is kind of like
the most cool and ass day it's a cool
ass day it's the most cooling day yeah
for sure that's happened so I'm happy
about that
um it was it was it was bad it was kind
of bad if you walk outside and you're
just like
your anger is just you're incorrect
tipping I mean you're angry it's at the
Tipping Point you're angry at some guy's
ears so yeah immediately The Tipping
Point of anger hello I'm Matt at Denzel
Washington movie in 1999. this is
immediate the Tipping Point of anger is
where I'm at a Gene Hackman movie The
Tipping Point of anger so so clunky and
so long and he plays a [ __ ] summary
general you know I mean explaining
Crimson Tide yeah Denzel Washington then
yeah there we go see he gets his jokes
from somewhere babies
all right dude well I'm gonna be in
Stockton and Oakland California and
Hollywood California and Oxnard and all
that [ __ ] go to chrysalia.com uh for
tickets I'm gonna be in Raleigh I'm
going to be in Boston a plethora of
places and Albany so go to chrisley.com
to get tickets and uh check out my tour
Vlogs all right let's do it you want to
get in yeah so much looks like Barney's
gonna unplug the camera but it's all
good it's all good there's a dog
standing Barney
and he's kind of Frozen and he's gonna
do something here we go okay
it's all good
what's up you guys what's up big fan of
the show nice I got a quick question for
you
um about a year ago I got into an
argument with my girlfriend's best
friend's husband okay and uh it was over
the Red Hot Chili Peppers and I made
some comments about how I didn't like
them and he took really personal offense
to it okay I kind of spiraled out of
control and I was trying to make light
of the situation but um anyways he got
really offended and uh made some
comments that ended up my girlfriend and
I stormed out come on whoa
um long story short I haven't talked to
him in about a year
we've got a wedding coming up that we're
uh gonna see him at and I'm not sure how
to actually approach the situation or
say hi or you know what I should do so
if you got some advice let me know I got
it I got it I got it 100 I know I got it
I got the number one thing but first
just be real quick okay was that me
because I would have reacted that way
too if he said I don't like the Red Hot
Chili Peppers I would have eviscerated
him as a person on Earth I would have
torn to shreds his appearance wow I
would have Turner shreds his past
history
uh but go ahead you you uh I have the
answer go to the wedding look you don't
wanna you don't want to [ __ ]
you don't want to live with this [ __ ]
it's so annoying also who gives a [ __ ]
who likes the Red Hot Chili Peppers or
not if you don't like the Red Hot Chili
Peppers fine you know he does obviously
and he's very passionate about it now
that's so [ __ ] dorky that he would
let he would be so angry that you said
you didn't like that Red Hot Chili
Peppers I don't know what your side of
the street in all of this is but I will
say this at the wedding you don't want
to you don't want to [ __ ] you don't
want it to be weird you're gonna end up
seeing them again so just squash them
even this is how you squash it
you have dinner all this [ __ ] you go up
to the band or the DJ or whatever and
you say
play Under the Bridge yeah okay is this
what you're gonna say but I was gonna
say different you do your version I'll
do play Under the Bridge and then when
it happens you guys will 100 make eye
contact and when you do it will be one
of the most beautiful things you walk
out to the middle of the dance floor and
you go like this and you wait for him
and while he walks up to you just I
don't ever want to feel
like I did that day it's very very very
symbolic right yeah take me to the place
alone yeah
that's good I like mine one I like mine
similar okay you walk up to him right
away first time you see him yep and he
just start doing it
sometimes I feel like I don't have a
partner eye contact yeah sometimes I
feel like my only friend you're getting
closer yeah is this guy in front of me
you make up the lyrics right and then
you're talking about him and then you're
getting closer and you give him a hug he
will not ever it will all crumble his
okay well so we have very similar
is more personalized but mine is more it
is nice because like he set it up he
said you know what dude I want the the
[ __ ] guy to put Red Hot Chili Peppers
on this [ __ ] or you can just go you know
play the other one what I got I Gotta
Give Up put it in yeah and then just
have a [ __ ] a badass time and look at
the dude and start dancing and give it
away you know
um but yeah you don't want to have that
sex magic a Sex Magic I know two songs
from them and it's the ones I sang oh
um and so yeah does that give it away
that you were trying to do yeah
give it away give it away it was that
and it was obvious because I did it good
I couldn't tell because you didn't do it
that good you couldn't tell because you
don't know music but I do no I know if
dude
that's what he says yeah but you didn't
have the right Rhythm I did dude I
thought you were mixing up two different
songs no and so I mean so hard so easy
to not mess that up dude give it away
give it away give it away now what I
gotta gotta get it put it in you you
didn't say give it away you didn't say
that because I did the [ __ ] nice like
the nice part that like we that like
you'd know like I didn't want to do the
obvious one if I just did give it away
give it away give away now that's hockey
[ __ ] but I wouldn't have asked was that
give it away because you did it back
because you're not on the level
give me the orange one what I'm saying
it give it a marriage you won't give an
orange we'll give an orange one so um
yeah dude I'm telling you dude uh you
don't want to do that squash the beef at
least do it for your girl and your and
her best friend so just [ __ ] tell him
to play Under the Bridge and you will
make eye contact if you don't you walk
up to him and you make eye contact with
him and then you grab his hand you walk
him to the dance floor and then you do a
slow dance with him I mean you don't
have to get too close right I mean yours
is more spectacle mine's more person to
person so it's up to you if you're more
of like you like to make a show out of
it do what he said yeah if you're more
like a one-on-one kind of guy you do
what I did I think I'll appreciate the
spectacle of it but anyway yeah maybe
yeah okay cool next one
hey Matt hey Chris I adore you guys to
pieces so my question is my husband has
an idea for a documentary and I need to
know if it's absolute trash or if you
love the idea so essentially it's the
rise and fall of Brendan Fraser oh the
Catalyst being his absurd clap at the
Golden Globes I mean is that why should
I tell him that he's an insane person or
is this a low-key genius idea let me
know no that well he's a crazy person
for sure but if there's a documentary I
would watch it's that one yeah but you'd
have to it can't be about the [ __ ] no
but you could center it around the it's
what he goes like yeah yeah oh wow we
bought it at the same time
you know the [ __ ] uh yeah remember
that when it went to the the
uh Gwen Stefani song yeah that's what I
was just gonna say you gotta divide back
uh I mean I love that I've watched that
at least 50 times how about the standing
ovation that I got for 15 minutes it's
everyone loves that he's fat a fat guy
now he's been fat for a few years but he
keeps getting fatter and fatter and
every time he shows up everyone's like
oh my God Brendan Fraser's so fat now
and of course
I mean I wanted to do it but don't know
beat me to it because whatever he's
obviously a huge filmmaker
um uh the Resurgence of Brendan Fisher
as a fat man he's in a movie called The
Whale and he has a fat suit on look at
this fat people are mad oh yeah that
that they didn't Aaron Aussie didn't
cast an actual 600 pound person but
Brennan figures fat as [ __ ]
he's already fat what 600 pound actors
are there they don't exist yeah exactly
which is why it's absurd can we get to
the audition right you find a 600 pound
person you put them through acting
school and [ __ ] yeah they they [ __ ]
die in the middle of shooting yeah I
mean it's just so unhealthy you can't
actually get someone who's 600 pounds to
show up on set yeah well of course
they're mad dude yeah um but that's a
loot that is the most ludicrous version
of it I've ever heard oh really I mean
there's so many 600 pounds okay fine
that can move okay yeah true okay a
12-hour shooting day that's yeah that
was like a tyrannical director like
darnovsky they die yeah that's what I'm
saying and action he just goes
the roast beef sandwich on the side of
their face so dick all right so I think
that uh don't do that documentary maybe
I mean didn't he he left Hollywood
because he got like assaulted or
something I can't really remember that's
not why but he when me too happened he
came forward with the story of his own
he got like uh I think like disgustingly
groped or something by some executive at
some I don't know I actually don't know
who it was I don't think he even said
but he talked about like the trauma of
it and how it like messed up his mind
for a while wow so he stopped working
and and now he got a 15 minute dude if I
was I mean he stopped working because he
was in Monkey bone let's get that
straight he didn't wow I don't even know
what that is because he got groped he
stopped working because he was in eight
movies like monkey bone yeah okay cool
okay and yeah and George of the Jungle
and every other day did that fail
George of the Jungle it wasn't the worst
of a monkey bone was like it made 28
bucks because just his I don't even know
what the [ __ ] monkey just because Mrs
Frazier went to see it can't stop doing
movies about animals you know he can't
stop doing movies where there's like a
little bit of it is also animation
that's his thing
but the whale dude I mean I'd legit love
Brenda Fisher I'm so happy he's in
another movie especially an arnazi movie
I want to see it you're too late though
he's already made his comeback I don't
think it's I think I wanted to document
through his comeback starting with the
clap oh oh oh through his comeback oh so
so like it was a fateful day and he just
it was a faithful [ __ ] in Gray and
then yeah right yeah it was a fateful
dead yes she did she said this is about
his fall right rise and fall she said
rise and fall
oh oh from the beginning yeah to the
clap that's even worse
it needs to be your clap needs to either
be the turning point or the beginning
yeah yes yeah and then just [ __ ] it like
this
yeah dude so bad yeah dude your
boyfriend is or your husband's
bullshitting or he's crazy he's crazy
and that's a terrible idea look these
two things can be true at the same time
it's a terrible idea for a documentary
but I want to see it yeah true okay yeah
I mean I've seen plenty of those
documents don't make it be wasted time
we'll lose a ton of money lose a ton of
years of your life but but I will watch
it I'll be first in line to watch it all
right cool yeah tell him he's crazy next
one
hey what's up Matt and Chris
um yeah uh
Lifeline um
first of all submission videos are weird
I'm suddenly doing hand gestures and
saying things and doing things with my
body that I've never done in my whole
life oh [ __ ] so she brings out a whole
new side of me
um I wrote in a couple months ago Norma
Jean from Southern Oregon I was asking
about a breakup and you guys gave great
advice I am feeling a lot better and for
real for real
that advice my life is now pimp and
Pimpin oh before we go I have another
question I post things on my Instagram
like a normal person like in my story
and I find it so incredibly strange when
someone brings up things that I post on
Instagram in real life what are you
doing why are you doing this to me why
the [ __ ] would you bring up what I
posted on my Instagram story that's
weird as [ __ ] good good
is that just me no is there like a is
there a rule yeah I think there should
be a rule there is advice dude that is
so something that is for me it happens
every day yeah yeah right yeah hey
how's the thing that you did with the
thing on it you know on Instagram I'm
just it's it's it for some reason it's
uncomfortable do you even my thing is if
people do to me I don't even remember a
story often yeah he's like I forget
about it five seconds after I posted it
yeah if you bring that up the next day
I'm like what are you talking about you
say that to me hey I I go like this I I
keep it on the internet do it right just
that is weird for some reason people I
think actually people feel that more
people feel what you're saying I think
more people feel what you're saying than
what than you know but I think that when
they see you that's what they bring up
and they don't even realize that they're
doing it that's what I think that's
complicated I think people are just have
no sense of what's good to bring up and
what's not good that's kind of
yeah they're just bringing it up
it's like you have red shoes and they're
like nice shoes yeah they're like
they're just red bro yeah yeah it is
like that yeah yeah yeah
um yeah so that is I I don't like that
either dude and I I think about it
sometimes and I don't know why I don't
like it because it's like in a way it's
like you're you're sitting and you're
doing your personal [ __ ] you're at home
and in a way you're you're giving people
a glimpse into your life but it's a bit
of a voyeuristic thing so when you get
confronted with it like oh you're on the
couch watching [ __ ] reruns of you
know what I mean Family Matters and
you're like oh yeah well you do too dude
yeah yeah you know you I want to get
defensive about it it's also like I mean
it's not similar to this but it's along
the lines of like if you were in uh a
movie yeah and someone's like oh what
about that role you played in that movie
it's like uh-huh it's over and it's out
there like now but what do you want me
to say about it what do you I don't
understand what you're saying though why
why is that like that because if someone
comes up to you right and it's like what
about that thing you were in it's also
annoying like it's just people don't do
that because they know that that's
[ __ ] annoying so then well so then
what's the thing thing that people
should be saying to you when they see
you nothing about that and what should
they be saying like how are you how
you've been but anything it's more about
what she should be saying and what she
should be saying is I don't want to talk
about that yeah
let me let me stop you right there I
don't want to talk about that but that's
so people think that's rude I mean yeah
you got to just be you I guess
or just act like they didn't say it
sometimes I do that sometimes I do that
and like it sounds rude but if it seems
like you didn't even hear them it you
can play it like it never happened and
then the person will realize oh
he's doing me a favor that wasn't going
to be good for him to talk about you
know what I'm saying okay sure it's like
people pick up on this wow and then if
they do it again then they're out of
your life for good never see them never
see them again if they do it again
straight up yeah yeah about social
situations
um I'll cut that Paul part of Social
Security I'll cut that like okay you
know what you're taking me speaking of
Pol Pot just kidding just kidding all
right here we go
hey man Chris has a bunny from Buxton
Maine huge fan of Lifeline you guys are
the best the advice is too funny it's
too perfect yeah keep it coming
my question is a little bit crazy it's
about my dad who is also crazy and he is
super into this holistic healing oh it's
called body code please don't endorse it
or ever [ __ ] tell anybody to look
into it because it's the dumbest thing
I've ever seen code and what basically
he thinks that he is some sort of super
power healer you can magically heal
anybody's therapy a tummy ache or you're
[ __ ] blind
and all he does is he closes his eyes he
mutters this incantation and he has to
be standing up and then he like waves
his hand over his head three times like
that and poof like you're supposed to be
healed
and I [ __ ] like just don't buy it at
all I like it no [ __ ] I make fun of him
I call him Dumbledore oh good I tell him
that he forgot his [ __ ] wand
and I like my sister thinks he kind of
got a little butt hurt because I was
like mean to him or whatever but I'm
blunt and I like to say what I think and
you know if I didn't know you're full of
[ __ ] and that you're not helping anyone
I'm gonna [ __ ] tell you
so I don't know what should I like back
off and stop making fun of him should I
like pretend like maybe
there's a chance he is actually helping
people oh my God the worst idea should I
[ __ ] spin move and tell him you're
not [ __ ] Dumbledore yeah yeah get
real like this [ __ ] isn't [ __ ] real
life
I don't know any advice helps let me
know thanks remember you said the thing
about Beetlejuice yeah maybe the
incantation was Beetlejuice Beetlejuice
and his head shrink maybe he did a body
coat on you yeah I mean the whole thing
is is it [ __ ] Eric Roberts movie dude
it's like body code it's called body
code he thinks he can heal people right
right you know what I mean yeah I mean
body code I do love Eric Roberts I would
that's another movie I would watch oh I
would if body code was a movie I would
have already watched right yeah yeah
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah dude uh but look
your dad is
crazy yeah that's so yeah he's got I
mean I hate to say it and I know doctor
but you know that's kind of a meant
those are mental that's mental problems
your dad is there's about of his mind
the body code unlocking your body's
ability to heal itself oh my God written
by [ __ ] Eric Roberts in 1998. if that
was adapted into a movement if it was
that easy everyone would do it yeah this
would think about [ __ ] like that oh you
could cure stomach aches just going like
this one dollar one dollar one dollar
yeah and then one dollar whatever the
[ __ ] dude and then I'm like oh [ __ ] my
[ __ ] stomach doesn't hurt anymore I
want everyone would do that ask him what
his response is why has this not caught
on like wildfire or why doesn't that
work on the stomach ache I have that you
just tried it out on me for I would like
to know the answer yeah have him do it
to you and then be like okay I still
have the thing now what what's your
explanation of that he'll probably say
well you don't believe then okay we'll
find someone who believes yeah and then
do it to them I want to watch they might
and think it works you know you know I
think my stomach feel actually does feel
a little bit you ever do that like you
think you have like you right you want
it to be better so yeah of course I
think it's I mean well that's like all
of a lot of religion anyway you know
like like speaking in tongues and [ __ ]
like that you know of all the things to
call it too body code is absolutely body
code is so it doesn't sound like that's
what it is no no but I think that you
should honestly I think you should sit
him down and be like all right Dad I
know I made fun of you and maybe it was
over the line but I want you to explain
to me why you think this works
give them a shot to hear them out you're
going to end up where you are anyway but
he'll at least feel heard right it means
your dad you don't want to like yeah you
messed up the whole relationship yeah
also yeah uh
uh yeah I I mean I I did I can't even
well you know see this is the thing
about the internet you don't even know
these people are out there doing this
[ __ ] and now we do and it makes me
actually sad dude oh it doesn't make me
sad it doesn't make you sad no I I like
it if somebody believes in body code
then they're obviously not mentally
healthy well I agree obviously I agree
and they're in some kind of turmoil but
most people are I know I know it's just
true most people are on the brink of
some kind of Madness dude
people don't think about this people
think everybody's out there being normal
everyone's like why can't I just live a
normal life nobody does yeah I know
everyone is either [ __ ] in their life
or [ __ ] in the head or both I know
it's very very rare that someone's like
actually got their [ __ ] together it's
completely sane has no like deep Trauma
from their past yeah everybody's [ __ ]
up yeah but like that's why it doesn't
make me sad this guy being [ __ ] up in
this way at least brings me
entertainment well here's the thing if
he realized that he was in uh trauma and
deep turmoil and mentally unstable that
he could do body code on himself and get
better but he can and he doesn't even
realize it so this guy's so deep he's
deep in some sort of mental you know
unevenness and then also can't even
realize it and then also can't use the
thing he's made up and body coat himself
out of that and if he did he'd realize
that it wasn't even a real thing to
begin with it's like Inception wow you
know what I'm saying also though that's
a movie and that's a movie with Jake
Gyllenhall that's a better movie in a
simpler way uh he is [ __ ] up he has
some kind of
sanity issue or like his life is [ __ ]
up didn't go the way he wants his mind
has been bent and tested throughout his
whole life therefore he believes in a
thing like body code right that's how
that goes yeah uh because you got it
because it's easier to dive into that
than actually face the fact this is why
I say that while my podcast recently I
was like I wish I was religious so I had
something to [ __ ] believe in and know
that everything was going to be okay but
in actuality would I have to deal with
is my [ __ ] I have to [ __ ] let these
walls down and deal with my [ __ ] and
there's no hiding from it you know
unless you are trying to not be a real
person if you could figure out a way to
but then all of a sudden you're a body
code [ __ ] people always say
things like you know uh Society
communities fall apart when there is no
more religion when God is dead but it's
like you can't put the it's Pandora's
Box it shit's out in the open we all
understand that there is no God right
like we can't just pretend now even if
that there's truth to that Society falls
apart when no one believes in God
anymore well we got to figure that [ __ ]
out then because nobody can pretend oh
well now I mean I know that there's no
God but oh okay okay let me just figure
out a way to believe in this book that
talks about God's body code Miracles and
[ __ ] maybe maybe body code is the answer
Society will fall apart if there is no
if there is no God but there is no God
so we have resulted in using body code
yeah Society will fall apart if we don't
use body code
one dollar one dollar one oh you're rich
you do it enough no but uh seriously
though one body code is is the answer
there was religion before
now there's body go great great that's
the sequel your dad is the new Jesus
okay cool
Frank Christ
hey Matt hey Chris hey here so my
question is how do I go about
negotiating for a higher salary when I'm
receiving job offers I have the skill
set I have the background I have the
education and I have the work ethic to
back up being paid more I just don't
know how to ask without asking plainly
can I have more money please so anyhow
would be greatly appreciated thanks bye
honestly the way she just said that was
was literally perfect yeah she's she's
so like like her her manner is so
pleasant all she needs to do is
literally say that you know little yeah
exactly you can say it exactly like that
to an employer that's how you do it that
that was good and I understand it's hard
when you're actually in the room across
from an employee is I know but that's
the thing that's it what you just gotta
deal with that that's one of your uh
what do you call it paths you got to
deal with that because it's
uncomfortable and you're not going to be
somebody out there using body code on
yourself to try and get through it you
got to deal with these emotions this is
something that you need about that you
need to ask for that and I [ __ ] by
the way love it can I have more money
please she said that's but that's
hilarious can I have more money so this
is my salary can I have my money please
that would be a [ __ ] uh if I was your
boss dude yeah you're gonna get it you
gotta raise yeah
um no but for real though what you just
said the way you talked about yourself
it's all it's all right wrapped into
that right there that's all you got to
do yeah figure out how to say that to an
employer uh maybe don't tell them that
video because it said Deez Nuts Deez
Nuts might be distracting but you know
what I'm saying yeah you know that's a
great one she's
it's about like you were saying you just
gotta ha push through right the fear of
asking you deserve it you know you
deserve it you're qualified you know
you're qualified you have the experience
you know you have the experience all you
got to do is say what you just said to
us to the employer get through that
initial like fear and once you're saying
it once you've opened your mouth and
begun saying it it's easy from there oh
yeah it's just about starting opening
like the the seal you don't want to be
somebody who doesn't speak up and [ __ ]
go so there we go
all right next
hey Chris hey Matt Ally here from North
Carolina
so I have more of like a question or a
request
um me and my sister are really close my
oldest sister so I'm the youngest so
obviously I've never had an original
thought in my life of course but I have
her to thank for my humor my music taste
all of that she really just molded me
into the woman I am today and I was
thinking about her Christmas gift and
she loves Chris and Matt she loves
Chris's stand up
um I wanted to get her the oops button
and you don't sell it anymore or either
it's not on your site anymore I don't
know are you gonna sell those again if
you are will you let me know yeah we are
uh anyways guys life of ribs thank you
so much just let me know I was selling
them again uh we just we ran out and
then we're restocking but her voice is
the most amazing voice I've ever heard
on anyone can she sing she could sing I
have actually advice she also on top of
the episode and get like maybe be a
picture of my high-res picture of me and
blow it up like a poster yeah for her
room I think she would like that and the
oops Yeah and then when she gives it to
her you [ __ ] press the oosh button
because that's a [ __ ] horrible no no
no no no no no no no no just do both
in her accent
that voice was she can't sing what a
waste it's just a North Carolina accent
what's your name it was very sultry she
was just she had a lower tone lowered
lower volume he doesn't get it I get it
I get a nice voice but you're acting
like it's like no but it was a beautiful
fruit in the world I tell you if she
can't sing she should it's too late now
she's you know what I mean what does
this have to do with singing if she was
nine and worked on it dude she would be
[ __ ] absolutely she wouldn't be doing
having a speaking voice doesn't mean you
have a great singing voice that's not
how that works but um it does it but
that kind of speaking voice dude if she
just sang a little bit of Happy Birthday
Mr President or something like that like
a sexy a very sultry doesn't have to be
dude well that was oh yeah that was but
like okay she could also be like well I
don't ever wanna be like I did that too
I feel whatever it is you know I'm sure
she likes the Red Hot Chili Peppers but
that was amazing dude also I'll be in
North Carolina North kakalaki uh Raleigh
if you want to come out and see me
tickets at crystalia.com Raleigh North
Carolina all right let's do it next get
her that for Christmas
happy birthday
Oh I thought it was Christmas okay Chris
and Mom my name is Audrey hi Audrey I
live in Clarksville Tennessee I moved
here three months ago from Nashville
Tennessee
um I like it here because everybody
seems to be a little bit more like on
the moderate path of thinking which is
just more my brand
um I'm a barber and kind of my gimmick
I mean yeah I deliver a great haircut
but also right on my gimmick is that
like my comedian make people laugh I've
had some co-workers
one co-worker complained that I guess
some of my jokes made some clients
uncomfortable
how do you strike a balance between
making like an abrasive joke but also
not taking away inherently like The
Liberation I feel like that comes along
with being able to be a comedian like I
don't want to dumb down my comedy just
because like people are offended I mean
anyways okay you are a barber not a
community well that this is right there
this is why I wouldn't do anything but
be a comedian because I couldn't like if
you put me in a regular job I'm getting
fired immediately because I made an
off-color joke right so but she said
abrasive I mean how abrasive are we
talking about like [ __ ] fat she's
like there's oh your hair [ __ ] blacks
like what how how like just like my
son's here actually how abrasive are you
being you know Asians can't drive right
just yeah you know what I mean just
an Asian okay but I think the way I the
way to think of it is that you are
actually a barber not a comedian I don't
want to dumb down my comments
lead you have to lead with being a
barber if people in the shop are getting
uncomfortable because your jokes are
over some line that people are making
people uncomfortable you don't
you shouldn't think of it like oh I
don't sacrifice my comedy you have to
think of it like Oh I'm a barber I gotta
scale it back a little bit and I I got
fired from being a barber white because
I wanted me to sacrifice my comedy yeah
it just doesn't like you you know what
we're saying it doesn't line up it's
just the unfortunate [ __ ] thing here
that you got to deal with you are you
could get fired yeah I mean you're gonna
get fired there's HR yeah you're gonna
get fired you're gonna get fired if you
keep doing it you gotta clean it up dude
like the floor at the end of the [ __ ]
the floor at the end of the haircut it
got cleaned up dude yeah same idea yeah
you know you got cleaned up because if
you don't clean up you're gonna get
fired you don't clean up the hair you're
gonna get fired you don't get up your
potty talk you're fired yeah although we
are dealing with somebody in Clarksville
you know that you know that's just the
monkeys right the monkeys
they're doing a cover of it but yeah
okay here we come walking down the
street
get the funniest looks from oh okay well
so she is
um gonna have to sacrifice some of her
comedy to be a better Barber I'm sorry
but that's what it's going to be and do
all your you know what how about this
dude how about this do open mics go and
perform actual comedy use your use that
as your outlet for your comedy because
once I started doing that I'll tell you
what in my real life I got way less
annoying to people because I was I had
an outlet to do my comedy right and now
I'm still very annoying and Matt could
vouch for this yeah but I used to be
more annoying I used to be doing bits
and [ __ ] now I don't I do I see the bits
for the stage and I'm more of a person
in real life because you don't want to
hide behind your comedy I did that for a
long time and it really [ __ ] me up uh
yeah anyway yeah I mean just you could
still be like the funny Barber but don't
make jokes that could be offensive just
just like not a good idea for a barber
you know yeah yeah unless you are
already vadasa soon and you can say
whatever you want yes you know I'm Paul
Mitchell right whatever but like you're
not you're a barber and you shouldn't be
making jokes that are gonna offend
people yeah okay
yeah
Matt and Chris what's going on guys
I'm so glad that you guys got together
to finally collaborate on something
um anyways I'm gonna keep this short and
sweet because I don't think this is
allowed but I have any advices for you
Chris really quickly uh Matt might be
doing you dirty a little bit every time
you promo your hats you're saying you're
not a hat guy I used to have long hair
myself
tucked their hair behind the ears bro
you're gonna look you're gonna look
killer it's gonna change your entire
Matt does it and he hasn't been telling
you he has not been helping you out I'm
telling you bro it's gonna change the
game hope it helps love you guys gang
gang I don't have a hat do I have a hat
I don't know do you have a hat you know
I'm not the Hat keeper no hats I would
have tried it but I don't here's the
thing and I I know this I I I get it
different he doesn't understand this guy
doesn't understand okay what's what you
just some people don't look good in half
yeah that's me dude I know and you've
said that on this podcast before no I've
never said that I'm saying it now it's
my coming out party uh he brought it out
of me you know but no that's not this
guy
you don't understand dude oh what this
guy doesn't understand yeah yeah yeah
oh oh nice throw okay
well you don't make that face
[Music]
don't make that face put it on hey am I
not a hacker you look like an undercover
cop now you look like an undercover cop
you know hi guys did you like to buy any
drugs
hello man
I mean a robot
yeah but I know what he's saying but
like it's still uh still looks so bad I
look even worse loosen it you know hey
is there any drugs going on in this area
no I'd like some
remember the yamaka would have bring the
way the Wayne's movie no it looks like
well you got a yamaka with a brim yeah
hi guys doing any shootings let's see
look at me now it's bad you're wrong
guys doing any shooting any planned
shootings coming up guys
the gun falls out oh God
yeah do it
nice toss though yeah you guys both got
Golden Arms that was good um all right
uh yeah dude I just don't look good in a
hat man I'm sorry I wish I did I look
fine in a beanie but it's always too hot
for a [ __ ] yeah I can't wear that
many beanies in L.A yeah
all right
unless you're me hi boys so I have an ex
from several years ago that was recently
murdered by his ex-girlfriend hold on
stop it
wait a minute her ex
was murdered by his ex-girlfriend is
that what she just said
whoa dude why are you not reacting I am
reacting that's how you react Stillness
that's good it's good for acting I'm
like Al Pacino you're Robert De Niro
right start it over please that's she's
talking I'm like oh wow she murdered
them and you're like I need to hear it
again all right okay
so I have an ex from several years ago
that was recently murdered by his
ex-girlfriend not me another one and um
honestly it was probably deserved uh he
oh
yeah
um I was shocked obviously when I found
out but not terribly sad I went to the
funeral cried a little bit moved on with
my life uh it was fine like I didn't
really feel sadness I think that was
normal because it was so long ago and it
was like a short
passionate thing when I was young
um
but it's been a month and I have been
having nightmares about him
being murdered and other terrible things
like that and then the next day just is
consumed by me thinking about that dream
and I cannot uh I don't know what to do
to make it stop because it keeps
happening and it's a lot so if you could
help me out with what I need to do in my
head thanks
yeah I mean I think honestly I don't I'm
not even qualified to give proper advice
for something like that I think what
you're experiencing though is probably
extremely common when something like
this happens I mean maybe it's like you
didn't really process it when it
happened when you heard about it through
the funeral maybe you weren't crying
because you were too much in shock yeah
and now it's like your brain is sort of
working its way through it you didn't
deal with it in your subconscious
whatever you want to whatever you
believe about dreams you could be just
your jumble of thoughts bouncing off of
each other when you go to sleep and your
brain runs wild what I would say is I
think there's like I don't know the
names of them there's like groups for
people who get together about about
loved ones who have or former loved ones
who have died uh or or been killed or in
some horrible circumstance I would I
would recommend looking into that
because they're gonna have way better
advice than either one of us could
possibly dude I just think that you're
not dealing with this [ __ ] and that's
why you weren't sad in the funeral and
the knowledge while you're having dreams
because it's going to come out either
way through your eyes or through your
[ __ ] sleep you know your mind and
during your sleep and you got to deal
with this [ __ ] because I can tell
already by the way she's talking about
it and like you said you're not
qualified to talk about it but I am
because I'm a comedian and like I see
her face talking about it and like dude
this is a painful [ __ ] thing man I'm
very loaded when she says yeah yeah he
deserved it yeah I mean there's so much
to unpack here dude you pause and you
almost got into it yep and she did it
look into that maybe a little bit but
you gotta see a therapist right there's
something betterhelp.com dude something
uh or imagine.com frankly just kidding
well uh that's not really the ideal one
for me uh yeah wow wow though that's
[ __ ] heavy I don't know if we ever
had one like that absolutely wow uh so
far but yeah that's crazy uh go see a
100 grocery therapist go to better help
yeah and absolutely wow
better help slash betterhelp.com
Lifeline go there yeah that is
absolutely wow
I mean you know just having a stroke
three [ __ ] oh yeah that is my
life as you may recall I'm the guy whose
girlfriend got her kids taken away by
her demon of a mother
um please unfortunately since all that
went down we have since broken up okay
now I could talk [ __ ] about how she
slowly undermined my confidence and
sense of self-worth to the point where I
don't even recognize myself but instead
I'll just say
the breakup has gotten really messy and
now it's at the point or I just want to
get the [ __ ] out of this shitty little
Midwest town and move on with my life
yeah yeah my question for you is
now one of her friends has recently
reached out asking if I'm okay saying
she's going through a breakup too we're
kind of in the same boat and we've been
talking and I kind of think she wants me
to take her to Bronx City you know I
think so should I do it do I just be a
little shitty for once in a while let's
take the rebound [ __ ] my ex's friend and
skip town
oh Jesus I mean well he's laughing about
it we love you dude yeah we do good for
you what a [ __ ] crazy few months for
this guy I love how he always is doing
the videos before he walks into work and
it's like I don't remember him having
that specific uniform yeah the quality
in or whatever oh really I think uh
first of all
amazing attitude for having gone through
such a crazy roller coaster so good for
you in that sense but I think that if
she I mean look the the at the end of
the day your ex-girlfriend who you went
out through all this [ __ ] for and with
is still the daughter of her yeah that's
what I was gonna say and they clearly
got some issues that they haven't worked
out the daughter probably has some
residual [ __ ] from growing up with a mom
like that that she needs to work through
on her own it's not surprising that she
was difficult to be with uh it's not
surprising that as you say she
undermined your confidence made you into
a shallow version that you were I mean
we can blame people all we want true
though making him feel worse but like uh
yeah
all you do is eat [ __ ] hummus
sandwiches dude like
I'm getting the point which is you don't
have to [ __ ] feel bad at this point
you've been through so much do a little
something for yourself [ __ ] the friend
dude everyone in this situation is not
thinking clearly because of the
situation don't this is the mother of
your kids don't no no they're not his
kids remember they're not his kids he
loves them they wanted to let be let in
closer but the mother and and his
girlfriend oh well then way different
yeah way difference okay okay okay yeah
just basically
um I still think it's it'll be you're
gonna make it worse for yourself if you
have sex with this woman [ __ ] her dude
[ __ ]
he wants to move out of the city anyway
I I yeah
but he's doing karate I I I I I but I
think but yeah but he's talking about
should I didn't he [ __ ] say uh take
her with him or no am I making that up
he's he's at the end he made a joke
about should I just that was a joke
don't do that should I be a little
shitty yeah and and [ __ ] her friend and
skip town with her yeah just I I if you
like her I don't know man it's it's you
know it's a little different sometimes
like I obviously different guys have
different options and maybe it if if
shit's a little dry out there I don't
know what kind of town you're in and
what job you have and that's important
to women and like what what you uh what
what you bring to the table shall we say
and if you're somebody that is like oh
you know hasn't had that many partners
and wants to sow some oats and you gave
it a good [ __ ] try here with this
woman then maybe maybe it is the answer
to to to kind of see what's up and take
her to wrong City but also you're gonna
make [ __ ] worse for you definitely it's
gonna make things worse for you you're
gonna bust that nut off but definitely
gonna make things worse it sounds like
it might make it a little bit better you
might feel like some kind of release
about like oh I mean when you talk about
it as a release it's hilarious it is a
release dude he's been under stress he
tried to make it work with this person
who made him feel terrible about himself
like it's finally got out of it and it's
like a cherry on top of the exit this is
the spin move [ __ ] A friend is the
spin move God right when he busts just
so dumb that turns around
so dick yeah turns around yeah
they're all naked yeah uh [ __ ] wrong
City you're gonna become the mayor of
wrong City and have a whole [ __ ]
shitload of problems I'm telling you
that just just just
if you uh here's it here's what I would
say though don't have sex with her just
because she's your friend ex's yeah but
you know he's not look at him bro no
he's not I'm just saying just to clarify
you know I'm not saying like do it for
Revenge that's not at all what I'm
saying that's a bad idea of trying to
get away if it's coming at you and
you're worried about being a terrible
guy you're not being a terrible you're
not you gave it the [ __ ] I thought
that those kids were yours I remembered
that they're not
um you don't remember I told you I
remembered after you told me but well
yeah that's remembering isn't it
technically but I I you wouldn't have
remembered without my Aid okay so you
say that and I go yeah I remember now
I did it
um so yeah dude I don't know man be
careful if you're gonna do it do it but
it's uh you gotta be good do it and then
move time it out right
gotta go
boom
what I want you got and it might be hard
to handle looking at the planes in a new
city and [ __ ] well
I think you should do it all right well
we disagree with me though but okay
that's just me all right do we have
another one
here we go Daria
no
hey Dream Team my name is Emily
um Chris I've been in love with you for
many years now I recently realized that
I am in love with you oh even better uh
my question is about my two and a half
year old and about kind of how we should
monitor what she hears what what she's
listening to and what she's seeing
that's tough um my husband and I both
like good things like comedians like you
that use
naughty naughty boy uh movies and music
that have bad words in them
um and so the question is you know how
much do we monitor that stuff around her
because
you know you can only take blippi
soundtracks oh my God those are like
Coco melon [ __ ] yeah I don't watch those
uh and also just any advice on terrible
twos wrangling of a of a gremlin child
like she'll bite me one minute and then
the next minute she's cuddling into my
arm sounds like my puppy help
uh I don't uh you know first of all let
me just blippi and Coco melon don't I
don't I can't have I feel like that's
making Calvin be an idiot every time you
send me a video I've got one there's
always some Mega annoying thing playing
in the background that is for him those
are the good ones look at when you go
home look at blippi dude he goes hi guys
I'm at an amusement park oh my God
that sounds good some adult guy with the
worst outfit on what was it what's that
guy's name blippi the man's name is
blippi yeah
oh my god look a monkey what that's what
he does Calvin's just like oh that's
amazing yeah oh because it's mesmerizing
and then cocoa melon is like the Black
Hole Sun video dude everyone's just like
I like bread I like bread and the
[ __ ] oh my God baby is demented dude
by the way they got a new blippi because
the old blippi got caught in a video a
long time ago
scatting on someone and by that I mean
[ __ ] on someone what do you mean
taking a dump yeah on someone
blippi yeah like he's German but of all
the people blippi did it
poopy
that's blippi that's Russian I guess
yeah that's the new one dude the new one
of course isn't white I love it that's
hilarious look I mean that's why a white
guy that guy no he's not white that
guy's not white on the upper right yes
he is no he's not I can see him he's
white blippi is a Filipino blippi is
Flippy is that racist
blippi's Filipino the new one sure looks
like he is yeah okay uh but yeah dude he
looks exactly like the other guy though
because of the outfit no because if they
were [ __ ] standing next to each other
you wouldn't be like oh this guy looks
like the same guy
sure sure okay yeah but that okay that's
all the more reasons right there
um so he shits on a guy yep and then he
got fired guys if the kids even knew
about that video yeah I don't know if it
was a guy yeah I think it was a guy
actually it was like I think it was more
of a prank not a sexual thing worst
prank ever and uh oh my God today I'm
gonna shoot on my naked friend what oh
this is a friend this is my anus
blippi
so annoying you know that that's less
annoying than that video right I mean I
believe that yeah
is he laughing
dude um dude so there's there's blippi
and then there's cocoa melon which is
the Black Hole Sun video is that sounds
more of my speed what I'm saying is
there's stuff like Peppa Pig there's
stuff like Bluey there's stuff like I
don't know any of the other ones but
that is actually watchable and I get it
it's not Reservoir Dogs why don't you
just show
them good things like like movies you
like they're not gonna watch it why
because it needs to be like there needs
to be some sort of like
hi kids to get their attention oh no
what are you gonna show them I mean
Casino from The Green Mile Casino yeah
but then they grow up to be a [ __ ]
killer okay you can't have kids watch
all that stuff this is her problem can I
put your head in a vice like you can't
have that you know what I mean mama can
you beat me with a French see what it
feels like and then blowing me with a
friend with my friend uh all right so
if you're watching that honestly I
totally get how awful that is right but
if you're watching stuff like Bluey and
Peppa Pig you can you can watch that for
longer so try to maximize that kind of
stuff that you're viewing and then when
they're not with you you can't you know
if they're just I mean I guess they're
two and a half so it's not like they're
at their friend's house watching you
know yeah too young for that [ __ ]
scared straight but like you know you
gotta you gotta you gotta monitor that
and I I have you know if you have
multiple rooms you know let them wander
around and when they leave the room you
turn on a little bit of [ __ ] you know
the good [ __ ] yeah a little bit of the
good [ __ ] you know put on put on body
code starring Eric uh Roberts Roberts
almost said Eric Griffin yeah
uh so yeah I don't know uh yeah it's
it's rough but you know this is part of
being a mom I guess right
it's nice that you're in love with me
though well she's in love with her
husband and she's in love with me she
said she loves you and is oh in love
with you okay she's like okay well now
it's better to be I'm she likes me more
okay that's fine she's like lusting
after me no no in love is not lusting in
love is like you're lusting and also
like romantically she's lusting after me
intimately interested uh with you she's
like oh I love you like we love you no
no no no no no we love our people she
left after me dude if she saw me with
the hat on she'd be like oh my God never
mind oh God yeah turn around and run
away no no no no she'd be like well I
lust after you no she's in lust is like
my [ __ ]
she's in love with me all right you have
another one all right cool
I mean hey guys
um obviously you can hear your podcast
being played right now but my question
is sounds like both of you if you're
anything like me and my twin brother
um does he have the same birthmarks you
guys have the bond where
I don't want to say like where one gets
hurt and the other one can feel it
because that's kind of corny but like
where you kind of have the feeling that
something may be wrong with your brother
or vice versa and also I'm curious as to
Matt Delia's drug use I don't think that
you do drugs dude I just know Chris is
sober all right and I have no idea about
you it's weird that he's would be asking
about drugs um well look first of all I
like that guy's look I'm clowning him
but that's [ __ ] kind of cool man you
look cool yeah I mean it doesn't that
star is I can't imagine getting a [ __ ]
for me it's a bit much but yeah you're
into that yeah yeah I do like that you
look cool
um it's jealous yeah it's all good I
mean I could do if I want to but
um I don't know if I don't know I don't
believe in that whole [ __ ] you know
touch me and see if my brother feels it
no he's I think he means like when we're
not even together like well we we've
actually sometimes called each other and
like hey I heard there was a thing over
in your area are you okay yeah yeah and
it's never we're always okay so that's
it's off if we have it it's yeah we
don't have the the brother Dar at all
I've heard twins have a thing where like
it actually is sensory like you feel the
pain that they feel it just sounds like
absolute horseshit to me but if you're
in the same here's the thing here's what
does happen you're in the same you're in
the vicinity you're in the same room and
you're so like uh uh genetically similar
because your brothers that there's a
thing that happens where like you you
start you you can mirror your sibling
because you're you're so close you know
them so well you're very similar to them
your makeup that you can very easily
Intuit what they're feeling and I think
the process that you're describing is is
just like a a more like actual or rather
what I'm describing as a more actual and
literal description of what what he's
talking about like he's sensing that
something's wrong because he knows his
brother so well yeah and that's probably
what's happening you're intuiting
because you're so similar and you have
so much experience with that person it's
almost like you're reading them without
trying to yeah you know like I can tell
like you could probably tell that like
I've been a little bit off my game and
like I'm been like kind of sad lately
and I can tell right now that you're
like whoa [ __ ] I am absolutely the
Lesser attractive brother right even
though I'm like wow life has been
pimping that woman is lusting after me
uh and his this man is curious about me
and my drug use uh I used to drink I
don't drink anymore I used to drink a
lot I don't drink anymore we're sorry uh
I I do I am known to double in the
heroine Arena
green uh plant let me just say uh known
as so Cajun known in some corners
Jay-Z why was my Bill Clinton it's
because they're similar I didn't help
uh I I smoke weed yeah
um I don't do anything
sometimes you know prescription [ __ ] I
take a trip to [ __ ] xani Island but
I've never snorted anything never
injected anything oh yeah obviously
planes I am known to take uh pills as
well oops oops but it was a mistake well
was it a mistake it wasn't a mistake
well it was dumb I mean three people
inside you no yes maybe
it was a mistake it just I was panicking
so I took too many uh yeah but okay yeah
do we have another one or no
you want to do another one no we don't
have to do another one
I'll do another one I'll do another one
okay I'll do one more okay okay
oh I'm so happy this guy's so British
you think so no hey Kristen Matt Martin
Chris even uh it's Jonathan leaving
England yeah hope you can understand my
accent okay
um I'm just getting in touch just for
I've got a bit of a neighbor issue and
I'm hoping you can provide some life
advice or at least some humorous Insight
um so basically my neighbor a few
dollars down she's had chickens in the
garden for like quite a while which you
know I can live with that so British and
I decided to introduce a rooster into
the equation and they said rooster likes
to make [ __ ] noise at all hours of
the day it can be 4 a.m
[ __ ] 2 p.m I'm drinking my morning
coffee
here this is rooster crowing man about
to get out of bed at 4am and close my
window because yeah it's just doing my
[ __ ] heading man yeah
um obviously I don't want to confront
the woman because I'm English and we
don't like confrontation
um and also she's obviously got some
sort of chemical imbalance yeah
acceptable to have a rooster crowing at
all hours of the day so not the kind of
woman who was bad side I want to get on
but so yeah if you've got any advice or
anything humorous to say about the
situation I'd much appreciate it dude
cheers man you introduced a rooster if
she introduced rooster you introduce a
bear yeah I we've been all first of all
hope how good is it I'm good like I'm
nice with it yeah that was good yeah I
mean I got to give it up that was good
he's so British though well yeah he is
and that's why it's good what you did
but when I saw his face I was like oh
you know why because I thought maybe
he's trying to hide his teeth right
because you know honestly he had bad
teeth but I'm saying is that really what
didn't no okay bro it's just my
intuition Intuit into it like he's your
brother you know I mean I don't know
what to do he's got a roosters
foreign
first of all get really good earplugs
they exist do they dude yeah I get the
ones that are like you know there's the
ones that you can jam in there but
there's the ones that you roll into a
really small thing yeah and then you put
them deep in there and then they expand
yeah I I know I don't think my ears are
good uh they're shaped weird they don't
fill it up because they pop out oh
really yeah they pop out they pop out
and so do I can't wear uh the Apple ones
oh I fall out I bought like seven pairs
I'm done I'm done with that [ __ ] give
them to me I wear they're long because
they're gone I wear the the things now
and every time I [ __ ] post a story
people like bro you can't afford the
other ones oh that's so much I bought
seven of them you're talking about the
airpods the ones that are free yeah I
don't like those I like the wire anyway
those don't fall out yeah right the wire
hangs it down yeah and hooks them on my
ears whatever this is very boring but uh
maybe you could weight them down put
little anchors on them
um yeah but I think try that try
earplugs they might not work because you
might have weird ears like him but they
work for me uh the ones you got to get
the foam ones though that you put deep
in and they expand and get into the
crevasses uh and then uh I think that
also get an animal yeah that get a
dragon is that is it makes prey of
roosters yeah a dragon
it's it's insane to get a rooster in a
in a populated area get an animal like a
fox or something yeah get an animal a
dog it's something that'll kill a
rooster
[ __ ] it dude yeah nobody you're not
allowed to do that it's not okay no it's
not yeah there should be a [ __ ]
honestly there should be a whole Brigade
of police roosters that come by and like
you're in the wrong area you're in the
wrong area rooster you got to get to an
open field keep it moving yeah get a
police rooster that's what I mean yeah
well that's not gonna happen though I
think you should get a rooster a
predator police a little police outfit
and put it out there with a billy club
on it you might want to get a few so
it's intimidated on yeah yeah all right
cool all right well that's it dude
thanks for that Lifeline
um you have a good time on Lifeline you
can go to get tickets at chrysalia.com
like I said I'll be in Raleigh uh North
Carolina I'll be in uh Denver I got
Albany coming up uh Oxnard California
just a bunch of different uh dates uh so
go to chrisley.com for tickets and hit
that link for the CBD thing 10 off code
light line Lifeline it's under the show
uh description uh and that's it
lifelinemerge.com for the good Lifeline
merch and mattdelia.com for your deep
dark uh or just really private advice
that you don't want to air out on the
actual show talk to me about it
one-on-one private for you we're doing
it big
love you most of you
[Music]